مساء الخير اذا كان حضرتك ما سمعتك قبل
كده عن الاسلحه الحقيقه تستعد من الان
لسماع هذه الكلمه كثيرا من الاسلحه
الارسال واحده من اهم المقومات اللي
تتسابق الدول الثلاث الكبرى في مجال
التصليح وهي الولايات المتحده وروسيا
والصين عليها وعلى امتلاكها وتطويرها
تعريف ال هيبرسون او اسلحه الهيبرسين
بسيطه جدا لانه كلمه صانك يعني صوت يعني
سرعه الصوت يعني اضعاف سرعه الصوت سرعه
الصوت اللي هي سبعمائه سبعه وستين ميل في
الساعه
العالم قبل كده كان تطور تكنولوجي السوق
الصينيه اللي هي تقريبا ضعف سرعه الصوت او
اكثر شويه لكن لما العلم التطور واصبح
لديه القدره على اطلاق صواريخ واسلحه
بتسيير اضعاف سرعه الصوت وقد من تعبير سوق
الصرف لا يعبر عن التطور الجديد سموها هاي
البريطاني يعني الحقيقه لها معناها
باختصار
طيب هو السباق ما بين الدول الثلاثه
تقريبا حصرا يعني ينحصر ما بين الولايات
المتحده وروسيا والصين قائم متعدده صارت
لكن بدا الاعلان او انطلاق السباق في
العالم في مارس 2018 ليه في مارس الفين و
18 فى الشهر ده الرئيس الروسي فلادمير
بوتين في خطاب مؤثر جدا
وقال انه بيعلم انها يعلن عن جيل جديد من
الاسلحه وكان الخطاب خلصت كالاتي انه
الدول كثيره او دول اخرى وطبعا يقصد بها
الولايات المتحده بتحاول احتواء الروس و
اضعافهم واضعاف هم على مدار خمسطاشر سنه
والحقيقه انه لا احد يستطيع احتواء الروس
ولا احد يستطيع ان يسبق او يتفوق على
السلاح الروسي داخل خلاصه الخطاب وكشف او
حب يدلل على تفوق السلاح الروسي في عده
منظومات من الاسلحه المذهله للعالم منها
فاروق اسمه
بن جار عباره عن صاروخ
هو وصف بانه الاسرع في التاريخ والولا يقر
صاروخ
يعني لا يقهر والاسرع في التاريخ اثر في
التاريخ لانه عشرين ضعف وسرعه الصور يعني
بتتكلم على اكثر من خمسه وعشرين الف
كيلومتر في الساعه
اولا الامر الثاني انه حل مشكله كانت
موجوده في منظومات الصواريخ القائمه الان
منظومات التواريخ القائمه الاهليه اما يا
اما بالستي صواريخ الكروز انها قادره على
المناوره للوصول الى الهدف لكنها بطيئه
نسبيا والصواريخ الباليستيه سريعه جدا
ولكنها غير قادره على المناوره وبالتالي
تقدر تتوقع يعني مسارها بمجرد ان تلاقي
مدرس غير مسارها استمرار يخ الهيبه
الجديده اللي الدول الثلاثه
بتطويرها واللي اعلم عنها الروس ممثله في
صاروخا رد بتجمع المسكين يعني فائقه
السرعه اسرع من اي صاروخ تم تطويره في
التاريخ حتى الان ولكن كمان بالاضافه
لسرعتها الفائقه هي قادره على المناوره
بشكل يعني مثير للدهشه فهو بينطلق وبعدين
عندهم قدره
يعني يغير اتجاهه في منتصف الرحله مش
منتصف يعني ضبط في اثناء الرحله
اه عنده القدره في مرحله ال ما انه يهبط
الى مستويات منخفضه وبعدين يبقى على الهدف
اللي هو ذاهب اليه
او لحين الاستخدام في الثواني المعدوده او
في دقائق معدوده النوع من الصواريخ ما
كانش موجود قبل ان يعلن عنه الروس او على
الاقل لا توجد دوله لديها هذه الصواريخ
وبشكل علني حتى الان والرئيس الروسي قال
الى هذا الثروه سوف يضمه للخدمه في اه وقت
ما من هذا العامل هو 2019 هو مجرد الاعلان
عن هذا الصاروخ
كان في حاله ارتباك داخل الاوساط
الامريكيه هو الموقف الامريكي نقدر ان
نلخص واذا كان على لسان وزير الدفاع
السابق اللي هو وزير الدفاع الحالي او عدد
من المسؤولين في البنتاغون
تتلخص في نقطتين النقطه الاولى هي اننا
اننا تخلفنا او تاخرنا في التكنولوجيا لها
يدرسون يكو ان كل من الروس والصينيين قد
سبقونا الامر الثاني ليس لدينا دفاعات
قادره للتصدي لهذا النوع من الصواريخ التي
اعلن عنها بدن اللي هم موافقين ان
الصينيين يطورونها ايضا لكن دون الاعلان
عنها وانه ال وزير الدفاع وقتها اللي هو
ما ووزير الدفاع الحالي ايضا استمر على
نفس السياسه قال انه
الاولويه رقم واحد
البنتاغون الامريكي والجيش الامريكي هو
تطوير الصواريخ
ودفاعات قادره للتصدي لها ولما سئل طبعا
الكلام دا على لسان لحضرتكم وزير الدفاع
السابق وعلى لسان
اللي هو كبير مهندسه البنتاغون المتخصص او
المسؤول عن تطوير المنظومات الجديده
للبنتاغون الامريكي
ولما سئل القائد ما يسمى بالقياده
الاستراتيجيه في القوات المسلحه الامريكيه
اللي هو جون
عن قدره الولايات المتحده على التصدي بعد
الاعلان بعد خطاب بوتين بحوالى اسبوعين
قدرتها للتصدي والتعامل مع هذه الصواريخ
المهله ال الحقيقه ليس لدينا قدره للدفاع
انفسنا في حال استخدم الروس والصينيين هذه
الاسلحه
والدفاع الوحيد الذي نملكه قوه الردع
النووي كانهم عارفين ان استخدمت هذه
الاسلحه ضدنا سوف نرد لاسلحه نوويه لكن
اسلحه مماثله او الدفاعات للتصدي لهذه
الاسلحه ليس لدينا هذا النوع من الدفاعات
الموقف الامريكي المعلن لكن الحقيقه في
عدد من الخبراء سواء من الروس الصين بل
والامريكان اكثر الامريكان اكثر الناس
اللي بيتكلموا وبيقولوا الحقيقه انه
الموقف الامريكي الرسمي غير صحيح لان
الامريكان شغالين على هذه التكنولوجيا من
عشر سنوات بل النوم اكثر تقدما من الروس
والصينيين ولسبب ما لا يعلمون ذلك وال و
ال و ال الصينيين والروس
يركزوا في تطوير هذه التكنولوجيا الفائقه
على انها لا نتحمل كل لديه القدره على ان
تحمل اسلحه او رؤوس نوويه لكن الامريكان
بيركز من الاسلحه تحمل رؤوس تقليديه ومن
وجهه نظر قويه تصليح الحمل الرؤوس النووي
اه يعني رؤوس تقليديا يحتاج الى الدقه
اكبر في تطوير هذه الصواريخ في كل الاحوال
اذا كان الامريكان
يعني اه الروايه الرسميه صادقه
الرسميه غير سابقه مش حيكون مهمه اوي لانه
الرساله الاساسيه في المساله انه في سباق
تسلح حول امتلاك الصواريخ
بين الدول الثلاثه
وامه هي اولويه للدول الثلاث
لكن الحقيقه من يسبق مين يعني يتاخر دي
مساله يعني كل دوله لها سياستها في
الاعلان عن ما تملك طبعا كالعاده دائما
الروس بيكون م سباقين في اه يعني منظومات
السلاح لانه ما عندهم استراتيجي غير انهم
يحتفظوا بالتفوق يعني امام الولايات
المتحده وغيرها هم كمان بيعتبروا انه
صناعه التسليح بالنسبه لهم مصدر رئيسي من
الداخل مش بس مجرد اه يعني تطوير الاسلحه
لازمه تتعلق بالامن القومي الحقيقه انه
الاسلحه ال هاي كلها على بعضها
على اهميتها هي الجزء من سباق تسلح مفتوح
ما بين الدول الثلاثه تجدد
هو كان في سباق التسلح بدا فيه سنه سبعه
واربعين مع بدايه الحرب البارده بين
امريكا والاتحاد السوفياتي ثم توقف بعد
سقوط الاتحاد السوفياتي سباق التسلح من
جديد على كل المستويات مع ظهور الصين كقوه
عظمى ب تنافس الولايات المتحده وبعد طبعا
استيقان روسيا او عقدتها مره اخرى على
الساحه الدوليه سباق تسلح ات ما بين الدول
الثلاث
واحده من مجالات اللي بيتفقوا فيها الدول
الثلاث لكنها ليست الوحيده وفي مجالات
اخرى السبق فيها قائم على قدم وساق اهمها
او ابرزها في الوقت الحالي كل الاسلحه
اللي تستهدف الان طلعت اللي هي بتستهدف
تدمير الاقمار الصناعيه
وكل الاسلحه القائمه على الارض فيش
الانترنت او الذكاء الصناعي وهذا ايضا
يقتضي منا يحتاج منها حلقه اخرى اشكركم
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]